[Music]
Cheryl Burke and Matthew Lawrence are
engaged
we've reunited and it feels so good the
former Dancing with the Stars Pro has
plenty to celebrate not only did she
ring in her 34th birthday on Thursday
her longtime beau popped the question
during their staycation in Laguna Beach
California it's great it's really great
Cheryl posted a series of adorable
photos announcing the exciting news
cozying up to her man and showing off
her brand-new bauble Cheryl's rep tells
ET she was totally surprised by the
engagement and that the gorgeous diamond
has special meaning it happens to be the
same sparkler her late father Steve
Burke gave to her mother sherry years
ago et has also learned Matthew had the
stone reset and added more diamonds to
create the custom ring he proposed to
her with and had the help of his and
Cheryl's mom he spoke with a couple last
month where they gushed over reuniting
after almost 11 years apart we are happy
such a refreshing thing in a
relationship you know just for it to be
great and everybody be happy for me it
was like a text message last December
saying hey wanna have dinner Merry
Christmas and then that was it then we
got back together
[Music]
[Applause]